[Music]
on this Saturday night the terrifying
wall of flames
it's situation critical in the Northwest
Territories as Raging wildfires close in
on Hay River it's not too far from town
it's really hard to process all that's
going on the tents agonizing weight for
thousands of evacuees ordered and
airlifted out
also tonight counting the losses in BC
the last few days have been a very
difficult and traumatic times for for
our community the battle ahead re-entry
and Recovery we're not letting our guard
down house by house Street by Street
plus the choking smoke blanketing swaths
of Canada
FIFA Firestorm the red card over that
controversial World Cup kiss
remembering The Man Behind one of the
world's most memorable catchphrases here
is the star the prize is right
global national with para Nasser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us we begin tonight with the wall of
flames that's inching closer and closer
to the community of Hay River in the
Northwest Territories with a dangerous
mix of extremely high temperatures and
strong winds have created what's called
a blow-up event forcing firefighters to
retreat and prompting the evacuation of
all non-essential workers
this satellite image of the area shows
how close the fire is only one kilometer
from the community approximately
officials say the blaze likely Burns
structures to the west but so far it has
spared the town itself now with some
cooler temperatures today officials say
the next 48 hours are critical in the
effort to reduce the threat our Karen
Lieberman has our top story tonight
fire is getting
well
it's not too far from town it's before
the sun came up Ian Myers of Hay River
set out to capture images of a fire
creeping uncomfortably close
oh brother
his entire community of 4 000 has been
ordered to leave even essential workers
anyone who remains is doing so at their
own risk the government said in an alert
there will be no emergency services or
response available these evacuees along
with Canadian Forces members and their
pets flew to Edmonton International
Airport Friday former Hay River MLA Jane
grunawagan is waiting for her husband
who was on the flight it's really
surreal actually and it's really hard to
process all that's going on but you know
so far so good I haven't heard of any
loss of or injury to people as a result
of this former firefighter Hans wiedeman
stayed behind to help this video he
filmed shows the fire burning across the
West Channel Dock and as of Saturday
it's one kilometer west of the hay River
airport and 1.5 kilometers west of town
center the fire did grow significantly
yesterday
and our team is going to be doing
everything thing possible in Edmonton
the Prime Minister joined Northwest
Territories Premier Cochrane who this
week said she's been asking Ottawa for
more infrastructure commitments for
decades we are in a disaster that we've
never seen before fighting over 250
fires in the Northwest Territories
Trudeau pointed to the ways the federal
government has been there to help now
with Resources with Canadian Armed
Forces with supports as people are going
through tremendously difficult times
tough times for neighboring communities
too Rosie bjornsson is in Fort
resolution east of Hay River which is
under extreme fire danger it's just
devastating and we don't and a lot of my
friends on the long side of the highway
to Hay River you know they had homes
there and they lost their homes for the
moment fire officials say they're
experiencing the best of a bad situation
so far it's much better day than
yesterday but still
none of the woods yet crews are
preparing for more challenging weather
conditions Sunday Karen Lieberman Global
News
those wildfires are among hundreds that
are raging across western Canada and
even if you weren't close to an active
fire zone chances are you're still
feeling the effects because smoke is
blanketing wide swaths of this country
it's particularly bad in the west an air
quality advisory is back in effect for
Vancouver and it's expected to remain
for a few days
NBC more Central okanagana evacuees are
getting back to their neighborhoods as
evacuation orders lift and firefighters
gain the upper hand there were more than
ten thousand homes under evacuation
orders there last week and now that
number is down to around 3 400. in West
Kelowna bearing the brunt of the large
McDougall Creek Fire 900 people were
able to return home Friday but with news
of some neighborhoods being decimated
uncertainty remains for many evacuees
who are still in limbo
is in Lake Country BC and what's the
situation like there camel for here in
the municipality of Lake Country just
north of Kelowna the evacuation order
for the remaining 400 or so homes is
being lifted this afternoon as more and
more people get to return home so do
dozens of firefighters to get some rest
and while the Wildfire Fight Continues
in West Kelowna there are continued
signs of progress I think we are all
starting to breathe a bit of a
collective sigh
although very cautiously
we're nine days in that's it and
look where we are uh we have faced a
wildfire of historical proportions our
community in many cases has been
devastated but just nine days in we're
well into re-entry and Recovery last
week three wildfires forced people from
their homes near Kelowna two of them are
now considered held but there's still
the massive McDougall Creek wildfire
that remains out of control three
thousand homes in West Kelowna and the
surrounding areas are still under an
evacuation order as fire Crews battled
that Blaze
a couple of hours drive to the north the
damage from the shoe swap fires is still
being tallied while residents wait to
return home but officials say at least
130 structures have been destroyed now
although things are starting to return
to normal here the community is working
to rebuild questions about insurance
paying for damages and farmers who have
had their crops and annual Harvest
severely impacted
primarily in just having neglect that
you can't go out there you know you're
trying to keep things watered the best
you can but you just can't be physically
out you're definitely having a detriment
to the fruit when it's basically soaked
in Smoke there is some concern with the
hot temperatures that the dry conditions
will make the firefight even more
difficult for crews in West Kelowna so
far the number of structures destroyed
sits at around 180 here although with
Crews continuing their assessment that
number is set to rise significantly in
the next couple of days pharah
karmali and Lake Country BC thanks
Carmel
as our climate changes natural disasters
are upending more and more lives mental
health experts say the emotional tool is
immeasurable Global News Health reporter
Catherine Ward explains more about the
cycle of struggle
when a natural disaster hits
[Music]
you alternate between
wanting to know what is happening and
wanting to just tune out a lot of the
the news
it's a complex and emotionally taxing
roller coaster the threat is real I saw
it for myself and for others waiting to
see if they will be next it's heightened
and then it's withdrawn you feel relief
when a fire stops moving towards you but
you know that often it's because it's
moving somewhere else this clinical
psychologist who researched the effects
of disaster says they can have long
lasting implications they might have
flashbacks they're highly anxious and
agitated which surface in different ways
people might not just report
post-traumatic stress disorder but they
might have other mental health disorders
start to develop so for example
depression anxiety substance abuse not
everyone will experience stress in the
same manner
who was reporting those mental health uh
concerns changed over time it wasn't
just the same people so for some people
they were finding that they were very
much impacted in the the months or years
following disastrous striking in the
wake of the pandemic have a compounding
effect we like to think that we would
see this nice trajectory of people just
starting to recover but unfortunately
it's being disruptive by these new
events which are happening for them
experts see addressing mental health
challenges must be part of the response
it is important to work with the
communities the churches the mosque and
and also to provide culturally adapted
care it's my hope that between things
like Crisis lines or care to speak that
people are able to take advantage of
getting emotional support after what are
some really difficult professional and
personal days right now Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
and while local governments ask Ottawa
for help fighting climate disasters
Federal cabinet ministers are being
asked to find savings new treasury board
president Anita Anand has signaled
October 2nd as the date for her
colleagues to find 15 billion dollars
from the federal government's coffers
our McKenzie gray surveys how the
mandates being received and where the
cuts can come from
after years of record spending the
Liberals are trying to tighten their
economic belt what we are committed to
is doing the things Canadians need us to
do
and maintaining that responsible fiscal
Foundation cabinet ministers have been
put on notice that cuts are needed to
meet a budget promise of slashing
roughly 15 billion in spending over five
years Finance Minister Christian
Freeland we also understand yeah I'm
just convincing you we also understand
deputizing new treasury board president
Anita Anand to find the cash we are
really refocusing our spending from
pandemic type spending to the broader
economic priorities of our country but
the financial refocus isn't likely to
make a dent in the economic direction of
the feds this year's budget costs 497
billion the savings Anand is looking for
only accounts for 0.6 percent of federal
expenses the numbers are just not big
enough to uh to change the deficit if
you really want to pursue Savings in
government you have to deal with the
programs but that's not the Liberals
approach ministers being told to cut
from Consulting and travel budgets and
promising no layoffs in the Public
Service they're very receptive to
ensuring that we are managing the
government's finances which is
ultimately taxpayer dollars prudently
efficiently and effectively that
reception lukewarm from some ministers
if program cuts are required for me the
red line is anything that affects the
quality of life for First Nations people
so that's my commitment to First Nations
people discussions between departments
and ministers are still ongoing but
treasury board has given an October 2nd
deadline Farah to send in their final
proposals
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you for
that Mackenzie now Spain's soccer Chief
has been suspended coming up FIFA issues
a red card over that controversial World
Cup kiss
I think this was uh this was quite
frankly a maniac who decided he wanted
to take lives
chilling details from the sheriff of
Jacksonville Florida after a racially
motivated mass shooting at a dollar
store the shooter killed three people
two men one woman then turned the gun on
himself
oh he targeted a certain group of people
and that's black people that's what he
that's what he said he wanted to kill
and um that's very clear and uh I don't
know that the targets were specific but
I know that any member of that of that
race at that time was in danger
police say the 20-year-old white male
shooter used an assault rifle with a
swastika on it his parents called the
sheriff's office after finding one of
several racist manifestos he had written
the government of Denmark is drafting
legislation that will make it illegal to
burn the Quran after a string of public
desecrations of Islam's holy book the
events have sparked protests and
diplomatic responses and many parts of
the Muslim world and as Redmond Shannon
reports both Denmark and neighboring
Sweden are now trying to carefully
balance freedom of expression and Public
Safety
mobs attacking a church in Pakistan
after accusations two Christians
desecrated a copy of the Quran
blasphemy can be punishable by death in
Pakistan
but in many Western countries including
Canada there is no such criminal offense
last month in Stockholm a man stepped on
and kicked the Quran
it is one of a series of such events in
both Sweden and Denmark this year on
some occasions far-right activists
burned Islam's holy book opposite masks
or the embassies of Muslim majority
Nations
protests followed in the Middle East
Iraq expelled the Swedish Ambassador and
a member of staff was shot and injured
at a Swedish Consulate in Turkey
Sweden's prime minister Ulf christerson
raised the country's Terror threat to
its second highest level the Canadian
government is telling travelers to
exercise a high degree of caution in
Sweden due to the threat of terrorism
christerson is asking swedes to think
before they use their right to free
speech it's more about
finding a way to address the security
concerns that have Arisen rather than to
to perhaps protect uh religious beliefs
similar tensions have led to violence in
Europe in the past most notably in the
deadly Charlie had to attacks in Paris
eight years ago
christerson has spoken with his Danish
counterpart about Solutions and has
hinted at a tweak to Sweden's public
order act one that might thread the
needle of upholding freedom of
expression while ensuring Public Safety
Redmond Shannon Global News London
remembering another animal activist and
Legendary game show host Bob Barker stay
with us
if you're one of the many who tuned in
to watch The Price is Right you know Bob
Barker was everything but sadly the
legendary and longtime host of the game
show has died Barker's publicist says he
passed away at his home in Los Angeles
at the age of 99. he was a household
name for more than 50 years winning 19
Emmy Awards and was also known for his
work as an animal rights activist and he
leaves behind quite the Legacy
when you think of the term game show
host his is the face that pops in most
Minds
gracing the TV screen for more than five
decades Bob Barker hosted the longest
running game show ever and the highest
rated
but before that humble beginnings Barker
who was part native American grew up on
a reservation in South Dakota part of
the Sioux Tribe he attended college on a
basketball scholarship was a World War
II fighter pilot who never saw combat
his broadcast career started in radio
then he was host of the then iconic
Truth or Consequences game show but he's
best known for what came after the thing
I hear is Bob come on down I hear it
every place they go Barker hosted The
Price is Right for 35 years and along
the way made news in 1987 for renouncing
hair dye going gray he had to ask the
head at the studio for permission in
1996 Barker gained a whole new audience
when he appeared in the Adam Sandler
comedy Happy Gilmore you know Nick Faldo
and I won this thing last year and I'd
like to win it again this year though
that left audiences howling his life was
not always filled with game show fun his
wife of 36 years died of cancer in 1981
and long before the metoo movement the
prices is right had a reputation models
often called Bob's Beauties complained
of mistreatment in 1994 Barker was sued
for sexual harassment and in 1995 he was
sued again after a model claimed she was
fired for gaining weight the scandals
hurt Barker's Family Values image but
the show continued ending with Bob's now
Immortal catchphrase help control the
pet population and your pet spayed or
neutered an animal rights activist he
walked the talk Barker a vegetarian quit
hosting the Miss USA pageant after 22
years because organizers refused to stop
handing out fur coats as prizes he spent
a million dollars getting three
elephants moved from the Toronto Zoo to
a California reserve and five million
dollars on a ship named after him to
stop Japanese ships killing whales off
Antarctica we'll be animal rights
activists of the day we die long after
signing off from television that's how
Barker hoped to be remembered the most
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser thanks
so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight sewer Canada is
Moncton New Brunswick until tomorrow
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
foreign